Here's how I would suggest that
you handle disagreements around
best practice.
Do the thing that the other
person wants to do first.
That's always a good way, right?
Feels inclusive.
It's going to feel terrible to you
because you're going to feel
like you know the right thing.
It's going to feel awesome to them
because they're going to feel like
there's some trust and willingness.
That's one way to go about it.
Maybe an easier way to think about this
is that there's no such
thing as best practice.
There are good practices
that are context bound.
As a matter of fact, the things that you
are going to see that cause pain inside
of an organization or
that make the interactions
between the development staff and
the operations staff difficult.
Those are actually the result
of earlier best practices.
So the thing that we need to be very,
very clear about
is that there's only good practices and
those good practices have a lifespan.
And so when you walk in the first
thing you want to do is you want to
develop that sense of
appreciative inquiry.
It's not, man how did it get like this?
It's, I wonder how it got this way.
What was the value that
drove the organization?
What value were there chasing?
What things did they see as being
amazing that brought them to this place?
And how do we recapture the things
that we think are valuable?
It's very, very easy to declare
the thing bad and then to
want to describe some new good state and
this is often how best practices work.
I cannot tell you how many times
I have shown up on the site
to talk with some executives or
with a team and the first
thing they want to know is Jeff give me
the checklist of all the best practices.
And in fact, I can't do that.
Even if I wanted to and
often I do want to because it feels like
they would be super happy
if I could give it to them.
I know that it's a little bit of a fib
that in fact what's going to have to
happen is the organization is going to
have to work together to
find a set of tooling.
That set of tooling is different
contextually from place to place.
Different vendors take different
approaches to the problem domain and
some work better in some contexts and
others and in others and
I think your job in the role of develops
engineer is to really to help to
help the organization to discover
the right set of tooling.
[LAUGH] Well,
what no organization needs right now
is another voice unlike
the war on which tool is best.
It's an easy, easy trap for
a junior engineer to fall into.
I would encourage you at the beginning
of your learning process to avoid it,
avoid it.
First of all, learn all the tools.
There are differences in approach and
technique that are super valuable and
you never know when you're going to need
that sort of super special screwdriver
to solve that particular problem.
So as a new engineer working in the
DevOp space, you're going to come into
an organization and often you're
going to come in with a list of
like, these are all the best practices,
these are the best tools.
And it would be great if you just landed
at a place where everyone agreed.
But in fact, what you're probably is
going to happen, is you're going to
land into a place where people are
already in sort of violent disagreement.
And if what you bring is more advocacy.
You're never going to get to
the place that you want to get,
which is the ability
to unlock that value.
So as it is it develops an engineer
in an organization that's
sort of can't find its
way toward a tool set.
I think is taking the stance of
advocacy for any particular tool is
not going to be the place where
where you're bringing value.
The most valuable stance you
can take is the one in which
you help the organization to kind of
CO discover what works in its context.